l'observatoire de tauxigny voir plus
loin et pour ça la société astronomique
de touraine sort les grands moyens
coupole système d'ouverture et surtout
télescope c'est l'ensemble des
équipements qui remplacé après 25 ans de
service les amateurs d'astronomie se
rapproche un peu plus de l'infiniment en
grands voiliers ce reportage de samuel
colin
à ciel ouvert la coupole révèle sa toute
nouvelle armature juste derrière posé au
sol l'ancien dôme en fibre de verre
construite il ya vingt-cinq ans les
anciennes structures faites en bois ont
vécu marqué par l'usure du temps
on voit que là il ya des partis qui ont
qui sont kiss qui frotte du plastique
sur bois donc au bout d'un moment les
choses vieillissent usées et puis les
rôles à cette coupole elle était
véritablement à la limite de plus
pouvoir être utilisés du tout antoine
caillou est un des seuls en france
capable de remporter l'appel d'offres et
relever ce défi concevoir sur mesure des
coupoles dans un diamètre unique de 4 m
47 deuxième étape pour lui neuf mois de
travail dans son atelier pour fabriquer
toutes les pièces nécessaires à la main
cette pièce là c'est un rail c'est la
partie en fait je place est la seule
partie fixe de la coupole c'est là
dessus en fait que les roues de la
coupole vont circuler effectivement
aller chaudronnés en atelier pour les
bénévoles de tauxigny cette installation
marque une dernière étape avant la
propulsion comme centre d'interprétation
astronomiques après l'extension au sol
il ya un an et le planétarium
transformer ces deux coupoles désormais
motorisé elles fonctionneront de concert
avec les télescopes également modernisé
pour suivre le ciel dès le 26 août
prochain on est un réseau d'une
vingtaine d'observateurs amateurs en
france qui vont dans la nuit observé à 4
heures du matin l'occultation d'une
étoile par un astéroïde et cet astéroïde
il fait partie du programme
d'observation de la nasa avec la sonde
qui est parti vers jupiter des capacités
plus pointues et techniques en soutien
de professionnels
l'inauguration des coupoles et du centre
au grand public est elle déjà en vue au
tout début du mois d'octobre